2024 Democratic presidential candidate
Marianne Williamson previously said
clinical depression doesn't really exact
exist that it's just someone in a clinic
who says you're depressed which is wrong
I've lived two periods of time that by
any
by any means today would be called
clinical depression but even that's such
a scam all that means is somebody in the
clinic said it she has now walked back
those statements and she says when she
said it she was merely trying to impress
Russell Brand that clip that you just
showed was a podcast that did with
Russell Brand I think maybe I don't know
maybe I was trying to impress Russell
Brand I was speaking glibly I have to
tell you
I'll accept her explanation even though
I'm not sure that I believe it I'll
accept her explanation to me the idea of
wanting to impress Russell Brand and
therefore saying crazy things
isn't super impressive to me